when they get what they want they might
think oh you know what I like that I
want that again I'm gonna keep lying
they're gonna get that again
so now the female is sitting there
thinking oh this guy's amazing but it's
all based on a lie
I've I found more that get what girls
will do is the guy will be Broad and say
oh I'm I'm looking you know he might not
say specifically what he's looking for
but if you say are you looking for a
relationship specifically like they they
usually tell you the truth yeah yeah yes
or no like no they might say no and I
don't think they do there's a good 20 of
people that lie no the right guys the
right guys the scumbag no I don't want
to say I'm talking about a guy that
doesn't get a lot of girls I don't think
it's just that dog or a guy that's not
confident in himself we'll tell you what
you want to hear but a guy that knows
what he wants I'll tell you exactly nice
so do you know what it is I feel like
guys because it's so easy a guy that
knows what he wants will just tell you
like the kind of guy I'm if I wasn't
with my girl knows this as well I don't
beat around the bush if I'm trying to
[__] a girl I'll just let you know
straight up listen I'm trying to hit
what are you saying and if it's not that
and to get that it's not just a random
girl either it's a girl that I would
have interacted with before obviously
you don't just go into random guys I'm
trying to hit what you're saying but
you'll get hit yeah this is what I'm
saying more time you have to just be
open and just I don't want to waste no
much time I want to waste no one's time
I wouldn't want someone wasting my time
either so if that's the direction I'm
trying to go with that girl I'll let it
know I'll let it be known from the start
I'm not trying to waste my time or your
time lapse where are we going with this
that's a good thing but vice versa if
I'm looking for a relationship would be
the same thing as well I'll let you know
from the jump not everyone is like this
yeah
okay I'm curious guy's point of view do
you feel like most girls when they pick
a toxic guy they know from the jump he's
trouble yeah like like maybe maybe he
might lie but like they can't girls can
smell other girls around him yeah I
won't say necessarily other girls yeah
but it's like it's like I feel like you
know I feel like let's be real yeah like
people know to an extent you should know
when you're being lied to it depends for
example like like I can say I love you
this guy don't take you on dates you
don't give you flowers you don't do this
you should kind of know you're not ready
like you can say whatever words you want
yeah I'm but let's be real he's not
showing it yeah so it's like so I feel
like I get that you know what because I
got man them yet and I speak to them and
I'm like
me personally I've never me I've only
been into relationships so yeah I don't
do relationships unless I've really want
to dedicate my time and stuff but I've
asked my guys and I said like why do you
lie to I'm seeing you chat to this girl
you're misleading a widow and he's like
bro bro she wants to hear this yeah so
sometimes it's like I'll be sometimes
you want to hear these lies because it's
like girls will say that sometimes I
don't want to sleep with someone unless
I'm in a relationship so you don't feel
like a a for whatever word but then it's
like this is a fake relationship this is
just for your peace of mind so you want
to hear these lies so you can tell
yourself I was in that relationship I
didn't know it too I thought I think
sometimes girls say that though just for
the sake of saying it like you're saying
we want to hear certain things and
obviously if your behavior doesn't
reflect that as in like you were saying
you know you're not taken out you're not
shown off you haven't met any friends or
anything like that like we do the same
thing
well some women do I'm one of those
women but to be honest from the get-go
is the best thing yeah it does everyone
does need a little ego boost and also we
all do want to be Charmed a little bit
like you said if you just walked up to
someone and said I'm just trying to hit
that yeah it's it might work but very
rare yeah
it's a certain kind of guy that can get
away with that yeah whatever certain you
know what I mean it's not everyone yeah
so I think people might not like it but
I think they'll respect it yeah but
honesty oh yeah of course it's honest I
I feel like honesty is the best policy
I'm just saying I feel like obviously
people lie because
sometimes people want to hit like I said
some people genuinely want exactly is so
much let's be real it is easier to lie
at times but then it's like if you're a
good person that's why you don't lie you
know what I mean because you like you
feel morally wrong but is it easier to
lie yes it definitely is that's why some
people just like yo she knows I don't
like her
but let me light up I'll confuse you to
tell the truth I've got a question
definitely though for you you know the
guy that sorry you know the guy that um
you're in a situation with did he lie to
you about where you're at
yeah
yeah and when at what point did you
figure out it was a lie
probably you don't have to you don't
have to answer if you don't want no I'm
gonna be very honest because I do feel
like
we all have to take accountability for
our own actions do you see what I mean
yeah
um
quite early on probably six months in
okay and how long has it been two years
all right
and you still like Maddie and love or
not madly I don't know like you still
got feelings for him
yeah that's honest I appreciate that
yeah
what makes you stay you just feel like
you can't walk away
um
or do you do you think at some point
he'll change his mind
I think I did think that
I definitely think I was maybe living in
a bit of Hope
maybe there's like a bit of a carrot
being dangled in front of me you know
when I was realizing or when I was
questioning certain things
um
I think I'm probably in a better place
now because I'm quite aware of what the
situation is and I'm quite ready to just
kind of you know like move forward which
is great
um
I can't knock him completely because I
feel like there was a lot of things he
showed me you know how we're talking
about actions speak louder than words
um and I think some women will
ignore that because it's not what they
want to see it's not what they want to
feel you know they want to believe like
nah this guy's right for them but in
reality if someone is showing you
something yeah you've really got to take
that in so
um how old did you say you are 33 33. do
you ever worry like do you want a family
and like kids and stuff I've got a son
okay who's 14. okay
um I would want to have another child
however I do feel like I'm on a
short time frame now yeah well because I
would just think
um because I I've like broken up with
people or like ended things because I
don't want to waste time and because you
only have so much youth you know do you
ever worry you can't find someone else
because you're still emotionally
invested with this guy absolutely yeah I
feel like I've probably done that for
quite a while yeah so I definitely think
that um I call it blocking my blessings
yeah you know if you're emotionally
invested in someone else then you might
miss someone amazing because you're
mentally still there do you know what I
mean
um
yeah I think it's just I think women
generally speaking of it there's a lot
of us that do need to really take in
what's put in front of us so and this is
a common like complaint I hear from guys
because like they value you know Purity
and they value youth right and so like a
common complaint is okay you passed over
me in your 20s in your early 30s and now
you're expecting me to come in at 35 and
deal with all the damage that the
previous guys have done for the past
decade and it's it's funny because
everyone's like nodding they're like
yeah that happens yeah